alors et si en pleine inflation la
solution était de venir patron patron de
supermarchés l'avantage un accès à des
produits locaux et parfois bon marché ça
vous semble compliqué bien pas tant que
ça à condition de partager le pouvoir
bonsoir Judith Gallo bonsoir vous êtes
présidente du troglo c'est le nom d'un
nouveau supermarché situé boulevard
Louis XI à Tours ouverture imminente
c'est le 27 avril dans dans deux
semaines précisément le troglo c'est un
supermarché pas tout à fait comme les
autres il appartient à ses clients assez
coopérateurs qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
exactement donc en fait le principe
c'est que les coopérateurs
sont propriétaires du supermarché en
acquérant des parts sociales voilà donc
c'est des parts sociales à 10 euros donc
il faut en acquérir 10 sauf pour les
étudiants et les bénéficiaires de minima
sociaux le supermarché leur appartient
et il faut qu'ils mettent la main à la
pâte aussi voilà donc pour pouvoir faire
ses courses en fait il va falloir
participer au fonctionnement du magasin
donc c'est une participation bénévole de
trois heures toutes les quatre semaines
ça c'est la condition pour entrer voilà
au troglos est-ce que ça existe autre
part d'où vient cette idée ce que ça
marche donc le principe d'origine vient
des États-Unis c'est même très ancien ça
date des années 70 il a été repris à
Paris avec la louve et puis maintenant
il y a une cinquantaine de supermarchés
coopératifs partout en France et là vous
êtes encore en pleine installation
775 mètres carrés plus de 4000
références pour tous les goûts et toutes
les bourses voilà donc c'est le principe
il faut que tout le monde puisse venir
faire ses courses et trouve voilà le ce
qui l'intéresse pour le quotidien pour
les courses du quotidien donc il y a une
gamme conventionnelle une gamme bio et
une gamme locale donc ça peut être aussi
bio et local voilà et toute une gamme de
vrac aussi avec 200 références aussi
bien en alimentaire que non alimentaire
est-ce qu'il y a des euh voilà c'est
c'est peut être bon marché est-ce que
certains produits sont moins élevés que
d'autres que la concurrence alors par
rapport à une grande surface classique
en fait la marge et la même sur tous les
poutres donc pas de produits d'appel et
puis des des produits notamment frais
intéressants
les fruits et légumes voilà sûrement
très concurrentiel par rapport à
d'autres d'autres supermarchés ça c'est
possible parce que vous travaillez
beaucoup avec des producteurs locaux
dans un rayon assez proche de Tours on a
on a travaillé en commission c'est les
bénévoles déjà coopérateurs qui ont
travaillé en amont pour aller rencontrer
les producteurs locaux et leur faire une
place vraiment particulière dans ce dans
ce magasin ils ont tout de suite
accroché oui oui vraiment ils ont trouvé
le principe très intéressant et eux ils
gagnent leur vie correctement c'est ça
le principe aussi en fait c'est eux qui
fixent leur prix donc après la marge et
appliqué sur leur prix c'est très
transparent déjà 600 coopératrices et
coopérateurs ce que vous craignez pas
d'être victime de votre succès mais non
il faut qu'on soit encore plus le projet
est de d'arriver au à 750 coopérateurs
en fin d'année là 2023 et de grossir le
plus possible parce que plus on sera de
coopérateur plus on sera consommateurs
et plus on sera de bénévoles pour faire
marcher le supermarché et payer deux
salariés c'est bien ça il y a quand même
de deux employés aujourd'hui alors
comment on fait pour devenir coopérateur
on va sur votre site internet c'est ça
oui voilà on peut souscrire en ligne le
principe c'est quand même de participer
à une réunion de présentation donc là
elles ont lieu sur le sur le site
maintenant les les mardis soir et jeudi
soir à partir de 18h30 voilà ça a
démarré donc on peut aussi venir le
lundi et le mercredi dans l'après-midi
pour visiter et
voilà et puis faire une idée ensuite
souscrire en ligne sur votre site
internet merci beaucoup Julie le gâteau
je rappelle l'ouverture du troglo c'est
le 27 avril ce sera donc c'est boulevard
Louis XI à Tours merci beaucoup d'être
venu ce soir sur notre plateau